does the new biopic elvis find its
rhythm or does it stumble and critics
help falling in love with it or has it
sent them to heartbreak hotel keep
watching for what they've said so far
elvis presley was an undeniable musical
titan but he thrived in other forms of
entertainment as well most notably he
graced the silver screen many times
throughout the 1950s 60s and 70s
cementing himself as a multimedia star
though he died in 1977 he lives on in
pop culture with legions of fans across
the globe so it's likely that director
bas lerman's elvis which features austin
butler in the title role won't struggle
to find an audience even though that
audience has had to wait nearly a decade
for the film to come to fruition
according to the rap elvis has been in
the production pipeline since 2014 when
lehrman attached himself to the project
fans got nothing but radio silence on
the film's progress until tom hanks
joined in the role of elvis manager
colonel tom parker in 2019
he was my destiny shortly after word got
out that butler would play the king of
rock and roll the supporting cast filled
out and printable photography began in
early 2020. elvis was originally planned
to debut in october of 2021 but a
cascade of coveted 19 related delays
pushed it to its current june 24 2022
release date elvis presley's widow
priscilla presley has given the film a
heartwarming endorsement and their
daughter lisa marie pressley has given
her stamp of approval too a few lucky
critics also got to see the movie early
according to the rotten tomatoes reviews
they've got a lot to say about it as of
the making of this video elvis boasts a
77 rotten tomatoes critic score with a
consensus that reads the standard rock
biopic formula gets all shook up in
elvis with baz lerman's dazzling energy
and style perfectly complemented by
austin butler's outstanding lead
performance that's an impressive showing
that the movie didn't earn by accident
in the eyes of many critics elvis has a
lot going for it while explaining that
it may take some time to cozy up to
elvis matthew toomey of the film pie
writes that once you do you'll find a
worthy tribute to a music legend he also
points to butler's take on elvis has an
especially strong selling point that
alone is worth the price of admission
radio times as jane nelson offers praise
for butler as well also mentioning how
lerman's famously flashy colorful style
couldn't have lent itself better to the
production george simpson of the daily
express notes the film is ultimately a
fittingly over-the-top tribute to one of
the most famous people in entertainment
history however simpson warns that
viewers shouldn't expect lockstep
historical accuracy advising that one in
many elvis-centric documentaries out
there would serve you better as an
exploration of his life story
joning su of awards daily claims elvis
has all the makings of an oscar's front
runner specifically when it comes to
butler's performance and the movie's
technical strengths i have to say you
could not take your eyes off of austin
bundler that said plenty of critics who
got to check out the film ahead of its
theatrical premiere weren't nearly as
impressed by the final product as their
contemporaries peter bradshaw of the
guardian notes that he found austin
butler's approach to elvis presley
serviceable but not necessarily
enthralling he wrote
as it is this is just another exercise
in elvis impersonation it's upper lip
twitching to no purpose awards watches
adam solomons enjoyed what butler and to
some extent tom hanks brought to the
table but solomon's writes that he feels
their efforts weren't enough to hold an
otherwise messy feature together richard
lawson a vanity pair presents similar
sentiments in his review titled austin
butler is the only thing that works in
past lerman's elvis
lawson concludes by saying elvis
presents a spectacular but has little to
say when the lights are off and it's
just the man grasping to find purchase
in the making of his own legacy likewise
slant magazine's jake cole was
particularly disappointed in the story's
superficiality and lack of interest in
exploring the nuances of elvis personal
and professional downfall time will tell
how general audiences will respond to
elvis and all that it packs into its
nearly 160 minute run time we'll find
out when it finally opens on june 24th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
upcoming movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]